oder hier einzel b hallo
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem video
wo ich euch mal meine iphone 6 apps
vorstellen zwar hatten viele danach
gefragt dass er schon ein oder zweimal
gemacht hatte damals mit meinem handy zu
etwas nutze ich derzeit für apps habe
ich mir gedacht und
dass ich das halt jetzt noch mal mache
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch vor euch
daher gerade keine face cam sehen oder
so aber das video soll auch nicht so
lang werden und ich möchte auf die
ganzen apple apps eigentlich nicht so
viel einigen sondern mehr auf die apps
die von anderen entwicklern sind und was
ich noch unbedingt dazu sagen muss bevor
das wieder alle die kommen darin
schreibt ich bekomme kein geld dafür
dass ich irgendeine epoche vorstelle man
ja immer einige geben die app und solier
da und an gutgeheissen hat bekommt der
doppel geld für ein rennen das stimmt
nicht
und zwar schon direkt mit den apps oder
nachrichten ganz simpel nutze ich
eigentlich nie ist eine ganz normale
apple app ist einfach nur oben links
weil die irgendwie immer oben links ist
die nutze ich nur wenn ich im ausland in
einer disco oder haben vielleicht einige
oder viele von euch denken die kalender
app allerdings nutze ich mehr als die
skoda ich auch meine noten und
hausaufgaben darin eintragen kann
und ich habe also was drin stehen wie
beispielsweise heute hatte ich einen
freien tag oder wiegen wie so was wie
wenn ich irgendwo hinfliegen oder was
weiß ich da komme ich irgendwie besser
mit klarheit mit der ganz normalen
kalender app deswegen habe ich dann hier
ganz normal foto sap wo ich ganz normal
meine fotos von habe panorama videos
longboards letzte löschte sachen und
jede kamera wo ich ganz simpel jetzt
irgendwie ein foto machen könnte oder
hier und hab ich halt oben rechts in der
ecke und nutze ich ganz normal für
bilder dann habe ich hier die youtube
app und zwar wenn ich daran gehe ganz
normal youtube ich denke fehler beim
laden zum wiederholen berühren das auf
jeden fall super center liegt darin dass
ich im flugzeugmodus bin da ja das hat
man eine ganz normale youtube app also
mit den ganzen sachen
mit videos und dem ganzen schützt und so
ich denke dass kennt eigentlich jeder
sonst würdet ihr das video gar nicht
sehen dann habe ich ihr die notizen app
der möchte ich ungern reingehen weil da
halt meine komplette notizen drin stehen
also geplante videos und so weiter und
so fort was ich halt einfach so täglich
brauche oder einkaufsliste oder links
und chevron zepp denke ich erklärt sich
auch von selbst hat denke ich auch jeder
auf dem handy irgendwie nachrichten
schreiben ganz normal an facebook also
da sind flugtickets drin und soller
steht über allem ein echter name das
mich jetzt auch umgehen öffnen dann hier
facebook wo ich einfach meine boarding
karten drin finde ich nicht mit ganz
viel papier am flughafen stehen muss
dick punkt c c ist einfach so einen
übersetzer da kann ich irgendwas
eingeben in die halle und auch da ich ja
gerade im flugmodus clip seht ihr
funktioniert ganze trotzdem deshalb ganz
cool da kann ich das direkt nachschauen
wer nicht gerade im ausland bin oder so
mails ganz simpel möchten auch ungern
reingehen aber mail lässt sich auch von
selbst facebook erklärt die auch von
selbst messenger facebook halt gehört
zusammen einstellungen wo ich halt über
mein iphone
wieso erkläre ich euch einstellungen das
macht gar keinen sinn app store einfach
ja kann ich halt auch nicht wegen
flugzeugmodus gerade wo ich halt mehr
apps anschauen kann
instagram sollte auch jeder kennen wie
so lädt das video obwohl ich eigentlich
im flugzeugmodus binden sind halt so ein
paar sachen einfach so leute denen ich
folge was weiß ich so was in die
richtung
instagram sollte jeder von euch kennen
könnt ihr auch gerne folgen hier laser
luca instagram dann haben wir linkedin
das ist so facebook für auf berufs ebene
so ein bisschen wollte ich mir mal
machen habe ich mir noch nicht gemacht
kann ich auch eigentlich löschen die app
also nutze ich gar nicht eigentlich
hatten denke ich kennt jeder ist so ich
nutze lieber karten als google maps muss
ich tatsächlich sagen weil ich dich mit
dieser karten app von apple besser
klarkommt von google maps obwohl 99 der
menschen auf der erde sagen dass über
maps besser ist dann habe ich hier noch
soundcloud direkt daneben wo einfach ein
paar sachen sind weil sie nicht das ist
halt so eine musik eppo alle möglichen
musiker djs ihre sachen hochladen da hab
ich auch eigene listen und so was nutze
ich ehrlich gesagt sehr häufig da ich
ein großer musikfan bin und auch immer
alles repos dann alles möglich also da
hält sich laser luca und da könnte mir
auch wenn ihr wollt gerne folgen social
blade kennen eventuell eine
youtuber könnt ihr mann serge gehen
könnt ihr euren youtube namen eingeben
können beispielsweise mal pipi eingeben
und dann seht ihr hier schon was der so
an täglichen abonnenten macht und seine
videos und seine klicks und so was alles
also das kann man halt bei der social
web sinn und halt sondern noch von paris
legt wieder nix ist auf jeden fall super
jetzt halt für youtuber ganz interessant
aber sonst denke ich für normale leute
jetzt auch nicht so unbedingt zu
gebrauchen dann habe ich unten snapshot
kann ich auch mal kurz rein gehen müsste
jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht gehen da
ich im flugzeugmodus bin kann ich ganz
normal bilder machen und die zu meiner
story wie heißt du bist nett meinte der
große öffentliche hongkong kraft dann
einig als laser luca könnt ihr mich wenn
ihr wollt hätten da packe ich sachen
meine story von wat ich zeige euch mal
was horst ich halt irgendwie so war als
18 uhr neues video oder wird ein frage
und antwort video solche behind the
scenes sachen soll weiß man früher
bescheid war nicht ein video hochladen
steht also das snapshot youtube studio
app einfach auch für youtube creators
ein bisschen ähnlich wie social bleibt
kann man halt sehen wie so die statistik
sind von seinen videos fancy ist
facebook und instagram sonne mischung
kann man blockhaus machen und allerdings
auch bilder passen und man kann dort
auch sachen einkaufen also ein bisschen
wie amazon und instagram zusammen
instant video ist weil ich erst netflix
hat aber mit netflix nicht so ganz
zufrieden bin und instant video ist viel
günstiger und hat eine größere auswahl
im deutschen raum telefon erklärt sich
von selbst kann ich mit telefonieren
twitter als ich bei das was ihr ich heiß
da konkreter computer global twitter
brauche ich glaub ich teil von euch
erklären jetzt den kurznachrichtendienst
ahari ist internet und spotify ist musik
wo ich meine ganze musik drin habt ihr
damit wenn man wieder eine app reingehen
ganz normal irgendwelche mixtapes und
alles mögliche also das ist mein spotify
dann ist das hier meine nächste seite da
habe ich die ordner fotografie apple
games travel social alters und des
spiels blitz blitz ist blisch splash
hier im fotografierten habe ich weiter
gramm das ist
sonne ebwo man quasi wenn man so ein
hochkant bild gemacht hat sowie das
iphone so hochkant kann man halt so
weiße streifen drum machen damit das
quadrat mäßig wird von thor ist eine app
wo ich auf eine app den text drauf
schreiben kann wie es die optik handy
haben die app die meisten nutzer bilder
zu bearbeiten weil die ganz coole filter
hat euro pro einfach um die bilder von
männern bau direkt aufs handy zu
übertragen slm msc nutze ich gar nicht
mehr kann ich auch mal löschen das ist
halt so eine seines web wo du halt so
dich mit zensiert machen kann sind
fleißig und kamera canon ist einfach für
die kamera mit der ich das gerade
aufnehme dass ich die sachen davon halt
direkt aufs iphone übertragen kann dann
haben wir hier die apple at wo ich
eigentlich gar nicht so viel drauf
eingehen brauchen zwar sondern einfach
die ganzen apple apps ich kann mal
schauen welches davon löschen kann hier
die iphone suche könnte ich davon
löschen das ist halt einfach so mein
iphone zu suchen und imovie ist einfach
ein videobearbeitungsprogramm und sonst
als dass alle sap die einfach von
standardmäßig auf my phone drauf sind
also kalender uhr itunes store und der
ganze andere stuff ihr dann kommen wir
zu games viele spiele davon habe ich
wirklich nur noch drauf weil ich sie mal
auf meinen kanal gebracht hat wie
beispielsweise park oder cross road oder
swing pop das oder so an dann habe ich
halt noch flexibler als ganz von anfang
hatte wo liegt das ist ein ganz gutes
spiel wenn man zu zweit ist sorgt für
sich auch und vier gewinnt und king of
fuß das sind so spiele wenn man in einer
gemeinschaft ist und man hat langeweile
kann man hier also zu zweit spielen
herzog ist sondern fußballfan die crash
kennt mich jeder blackjack sollte auch
jeder camp und mister jump ist dieses
jump'n'run spiel mit traktor und das
sind auch schon meine ganzen spiele also
ich habe hier wirklich diese neuen stück
und dieses hier und dann habe ich hier
noch blitze splish splash das ist eine
app wo ich diesen kleinen racker hier
ich bin total schlecht darin muss ihm
halt irgendwie von oben nach unten
kicken die ganze zeit aber dazu wird
denke ich die tage auch noch mal ein
video kommen also das wollte ich
unbedingt noch mal aufnehmen weil das
ganz cooles eignet sich ganz gut für ein
youtube video und dann werde ich euch
das spiel dann noch mal genauer erklären
zumindest versuchen dann habe ich hier
den travel ort da hab ich so sachen drin
wie in den deutsche bahn navigator
bahnverbindung raussuchen wetteronline
wegen wetter und regenradar verzicht
blitzer de pro für autobahnfahrten
staumelder
nach wenigen wo staus und vrs auskunft
das ist so der komplette raum weil wir
nicht mal in köln bin oder so bin ich
halt meistens mit dem zug unterwegs und
da kenne ich halt noch nicht das ganze
straßensystem des w oder ganze u bahn
und s bahn system in der ganzen stadt
deswegen da nochmal von straßen in
seinem u bahn plan band ist auch egal
dann haben wir den social ordner lassen
sachen drin die teamspeak und skype wo
ich mit anderen leuten reden kann wein
was ich derzeit wirklich gar nicht mehr
benutzt
snap das kann man hier irgendwie
bielefeld ganz gut anwenden wenn man
irgendwelche leben des karmann snap
dahin packen und dann kriegt man eben
die rabatte seiten ist für facebook
seiten kann ich aber eigentlich auch mal
löschen brauchen kommen lasse immer
drauf nutze ich nie eigentlich habe ich
mir mal runtergeladen weil ich dachte
wow dann kann ich vom iphone aus was in
meiner facebook seite posten ob ich
poste daini was horst die meisten
wirklich nur auf instagram mit snapshot
und gmail einfach für meine komplette
gmail.com dann habe ich schon den
letzten orten und zwar derart dass
ordner oder ganze andere schülerin das
also beispielsweise sport1 eine sport
app shazam wenn einfach grad im club ein
lied läufer wo man sich denkt sogar das
ist cool das kenne ich noch nicht dann
sagt er was es nicht ist und er einfach
was gerade im fernsehen läuft ergebnis
derlei was ähnliches wie sport1 also
fußballergebnisse und so amazon kennt
jeder tipico sportwetten unseren schild
macht nicht sportwetten
da wird man nur am von also ich hab
bisher glaube ich nur plus gemacht aber
davon wird man eigentlich nur arm von
n-tv einfach kurznachrichten
veröffentlicher publisher also einfach
seine nachrichten app die mir immer sagt
was los ist in der welt die panne und
wikipedia auf das iphone runkeeper wenn
ich joggen gehe diese app habe ich habe
ich eine wette verloren und dann musste
ich mir diese app kaufen es tut mir leid
dass ich euch die in diesem video das
zeigt wie scheiße damals vier euro
gekostet und ich will sie nicht löschen
weil sie immer noch vier euro kostet das
ist so kennt ihr das wenn ihr euch
sachen kauft denn die wollte sie nicht
wegschmeißen weil die biz das lieber
teuer waren
so was ist das sport1 fm ist einfach
fußball radio sind sehr viele sportler
auf meinem handy
lieferheld wenn ich was zu essen
bestellen möchte apfel like ist sowas
wie n-tv nur auf apple bezogen und quick
scan wenn ich irgendwie weil sie nicht
gegen den qr code scannen möchte oder so
nutze ich aber auch sehr selten ja
freunde das was hier mit meinem iphone 6
ich glaub ich hab euch alles irgendwie
gezeigt oder hab ich ja ich meine ich
hab euch alles gezeigt ich hab nicht
mehr als diese beiden seiten hier dass
die kamera ganz so schief ist aber ich
hab keinen bock das jetzt auch irgendwie
umzustellen für die ent card ich hoffe
ich habe das video gefallen wenn es
getan hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen ich habe versucht euch
alles zu zeigen ist ein bisschen doof
weil ich kann ich in what's up gehen
oder ein mail oder irgendwelche anderen
sozialen netzwerke weil man sonst sehr
viel private sachen von mir sieht und
das möchte ich nicht hier findet keine
app in der beschreibung verlinkt ich
habe ja versucht alle mit namen
auszusprechen damit das einfach zu viel
wäre die ganzen apps in beschreibung zu
packen